OK, so in the last 24 hours, the health questions
about Donald Trump have appeared not just
on Fox News, as we already talked about, but
the health questions around Trump have also
become a focus of a new ad from the Republican
pack.
Republican political action committee called
the Lincoln Project.
Now, we've talked about the Lincoln Project
a little bit before.
It's a PAC run by some prominent Republicans.
This includes George Conway, who, by the way,
is the husband of Trump adviser Kellyanne
Conway.
Steve Schmidt is part of the Lincoln Project,
former McCain campaign manager Rick Wilson
and other prominent Republicans.
They are a Republican PAC that realizes Trump
is a danger and must be removed.
Their ads have been going after Trump harder
and harder.
And yesterday they released an ad that goes
after Donald Trump on the topic of his health,
again, raising questions about Trump's behavior
over the weekend at West Point, linking Trump's
behavior to the last minute visit to Walter
Reed Medical Center in 2019.
So let's look at the ad.
Let's listen to the ad.
Now, some of these elements are visual, like,
for example, you'll hear voiceover and they
are showing Donald Trump acting bizarrely.
So I do recommend watching this online, but
you'll get a sense of the story that's being
told from the narration.
Let's take a look.
Something's wrong with Donald Trump.
He's shaky.
Weak chuckle Speaking of walking, so why are
we talking about this?
And why isn't the press covering Trump secretive
midnight run to Walter Reed Medical Center?
Why do so many reporters cover the White House
and pretend they can't see Trump's decline?
The most powerful office in the world needs
more than a week on shaky precedent.
Trump doesn't have the strength to lead North
a character to admit it.
We're not doctors, but we're not blind.
It's time we talk about this.
Trump is not.
Well.
So this is really quite well done.
Even the details down that down to the details,
it's very good.
At one point when the voice over says we're
not doctors, what you see in the ad is Trump's
old doctor, Harold Bornstein, onscreen.
That's the guy that Donald Trump allegedly
coerced into writing that bogus letter about
how healthy Donald Trump is.
So we're now seeing this.
I guess we would call it a sort of hashtag
movement.
Trump is not well, is the name of it.
And it's going much more mainstream than it
ever has.
It's happening thanks to right wing media.
It's happening thanks to a Republican political
action committee.
And to go back to the analysis, this is not
about Republicans are now going to be widely
concerned about Donald Trump's health.
That's not going to happen.
The importance of this is that there are large
swaths of the American population that don't
even know that there has been a conversation
about Trump's health happening for three years.
There's large portions of the electorate that
have no idea that dozens of medical experts,
both from the neuro neurology field and mental
health fields, have been expressing concern
about Donald Trump's health for years because
they watch Fox News and they only follow Republicans
on social media.
They don't know about Trump's verbal glitches,
his wandering off.
That time when he came off of Air Force One,
his limo was right in front of him.
He wandered off, had to be brought back by
Secret Service, losing his train of thought,
sweating with the dilated pupils while speaking
upper Trump versus Downer Trump.
They don't know about it.
So even hearing about this as a thing on Fox
News and through a Republican pack is introducing
it into their awareness now.
Ninety nine percent of them won't care.
But remember that in 2016, the election came
down to seventy five thousand votes in three
states.
We will mostly win if we get the turnout,
but we'll take any help we can get.
And if it's a Republican pack and Fox News
asking even some questions about Donald Trump's
health, you might convince a few people and
we will take it.
Now, there are reports about this ad being
controversial.
For example, this there's an article this
morning in the week which is called New Lincoln
Project.
Ad controversially questions Trump's health.
It's not really controversial if you've been
following this for years.
And there's a debate happening in this article
and elsewhere asking whether Trump's health
is fair game.
Now, one argument is, listen, Trump mocked
a disabled reporter.
He calls Joe Biden Sleepy Joe and says Joe
Biden doesn't even know what he's saying.
He is regularly implying Joe Biden is cognitively
impaired.
So that makes Trump's health fair game.
I disagree with that assessment.
The reason Trump's health is fair game is
because he's the president.
And we have reason to believe that he's lying
about his health.
His medical report lied about his height and
weight combination.
He allegedly coerced the doctor to write a
letter saying Trump would be the healthiest
president in history.
It's an empirical claim that no doctor could
actually make.
So I understand the concern from disability
rights groups worried that this is bordering
on making fun of health issues.
That is not what this is about.
This is about understanding the critical nature
of being president.
And when you have a president that no one
seems unwell.
And number two is dishonest about everything,
including his height and weight.
We are absolutely right to be concerned.
That's really what this is fundamentally about.